so over the last few years
things have happened like we all know
although it's not talked about anymore
we left the eu brexit brexit happened
we left the eu and as a result of that
as a result of that did that bring
certain changes
into the uk yes or no
yeah yeah it has it has another thing
that's happened that support changes
is we've had a lot of
legislation legislation
around hmos and property investing in
general
for example hmo licensing
is now a lot stricter so there are and
there are
i mean the whole of wales if you want to
get a property in wales
you need to have a license so this
licensing and this legislation
that that's come in more so um
as you think that's made it harder or
easier for landlords let me know easier
or harder give me a thumbs up
some people saying harder with a thumbs
down a couple saying maybe easier
okay another thing as well we've had is
something called
uh well whatever tax changes should we
say tax
changes such as there's a rule that came
in called section 24
and section 24 said that
you cannot claim your mortgage expense
as tax deductible which really really
hit landlords
on the tax side and meant that a lot of
landlords started selling their
properties
all right what what else there's any big
ones feel free to write it down and show
me
um i i i can think of one i can think of
one
we've had
tenants rights
so right now in the uk
if you've got a tenant if you've got a
tenant
who's not paying rent you have to wait
to evict them until lockdown is over now
do you think that that's brought a lot
of
discomfort to landlords yes or no
yes because if they've got a tenant in
their property and they're thinking well
hang on a minute
if my tenant just stops paying i can't
really do anything that's made a lot of
landlords very very scared very
uncomfortable
and some landlords have been hit by that
so there's been all these changes and
all these
problems and all this legislation but
despite that have property prices being
going
up or if they be going down which one up
or down
ah that's right so why have house prices
been going up
well half price house price has been
going up for for lots and lots of
reasons
and i could spend um i could spend
hours and hours and hours talking about
my predictions on what's going to happen
and all the implications and when brexit
came this made this happen and i can
make this really really detailed
or i could give you the really really
simple version
that's going to if you just understand
the simple version you're going to be
able to look a genius to your friends
and family what do you want do you want
the
the complex or do you want the simple
which one if you want the simple just do
this
this is simple all right i'll give you a
simple version
and believe me you know i i've sat i sit
in
many boardroom meetings with lawyers and
accountants and the council and planning
departments and consultants
and they speak all this jargon and they
make
everything so complicated
but all that does is it stops ordinary
people
by the way i'm quite ordinary you know i
left school with three gcses
i'm not too too smart i'm kind of
ordinary
but it what happens is ordinary people
don't understand the market i don't
understand
economics i don't understand property
investing in real estate and mortgages
and tax
because it's so complicated how many
reasons feel like this like it's a
little bit complicated if you give me
away
a little bit complicated right well
here's what my job is today
my job today is to make all of this
complicated stuff
this is a crash course i'm going to make
it really
simple so that you can understand it and
you can predict the market
in fact you're going to be able to
understand property better than most
property professionals that have been in
the industry for 20 years by the end of
this crash course
if that's good give me a thumbs up in
fact
the property professionals right
they hate me making things so simple
they're like who makes it look so simple
i'm like uh-huh
but all i'm doing is i'm just breaking
it down so let me explain this
this is how you can predict what's going
to happen in the market
so after if you want to know what's
about to happen in the
in the economy or in the market you just
need to go to this so
this is what the property market's going
to do it's going to go up
and then it's going to go down because
after an expansion comes a recession
but then after a recession comes an
expansion
so up again now you don't know exactly
how much it's going to go up but you
know it's going to go
up and then you don't know exactly
how much it's going to go down but it's
going to go down
and then it's going to go up again and
that is what the property market has
done
for the last 1 000
years that's 1 000 years
it goes up and down and up and down
however
over time on average the property market
goes
up but it just doesn't go up like that
it goes up and down up and down up and
down
now because it goes up and down up and
down up and down then what happens is
emotions
and fear and complexities come into the
equation because instead of people just
going
if it went up like the green line and
everyone goes oh it's just going to go
up
it's just going to keep slowly going up
then that would that would take out
any fear but actually fear is the thing
that keeps the market going up
fear is that actually helps us and
warren buffett says
that when people are scared because of
brexit and legislation and tax changes
and tenants rights
then when people are scared that is
exactly when
you should be what greedy
and when people are greedy that's when
you
should be what that's when you should be
scared now this is what most people do
this is how most people go about pro
investing in property
most people do this
most people go all right this is bob
and bob decides he wants to be a
property investor right he's all happy
bob he doesn't come he doesn't want to
go on my crash course because
because he's too busy he's a
professional
right he's a busy boy bob and on the
weekend his family time
so he doesn't want to go on the crash
course but he does realize he wants to
invest in property so this is what bob
does
bob decides he wants to invest in
property
and um and he sees the market's going up
and he sees the market's going up and he
goes right i'm going to buy
and then he finds a property and he
starts to speak to his mortgage broker
and then the market starts dipping and
he goes oh my goodness
well i don't want to buy if the market's
dipping um let me just i'll just wait
and see what happens and he waits
and he pulls out he pulls out and the
market goes down and he goes
hey
um hold on hold on hold on hold on i'm
going to buy now i'm going to buy now oh
i'm going to buy i'm going to
oh oh brexit tax changes
um oh but um
and then before you know it bob
is dead finished
gone six feet under and that is how most
people live their lives
how many of you have met people like bob
before
give me a ways of course how many of you
sometimes if you're really honest by
show of hands
how many of you could potentially be a
little bit like bob as well
thank you for your honesty that's most
people
that's how most people live their lives
and you know there's a saying that says
if five
frogs are sat on a log five frogs sat on
a log
and one decides to jump off by show
fingers
how many are left on the log i show
fingers
and people say four well let me
let me say the answer one person said it
the answer is five
and the reason is five is because just
because one decided to jump off the log
doesn't mean that they actually did
because there's one thing deciding to do
something
and there's a whole another thing
actually doing something how many of you
know what i'm talking about give me
aways
so the people that make money in
property are the people that don't and
this is a saying actually it says
don't wait to buy property
buy property and wait
because we know that in time
property will always even if it dips at
the moment it's going up
but guess what's going to happen what's
going to happen is it's going to go down
and then it's going to go up again and
it's so rather than trying to work out
what's going to happen over the next 6
12 months you just got to say this look
when i'm buying a house
i'm going to hold on to it and i'm going
to rent it out
and i'm going to make a nice income from
the rent so it doesn't matter if it goes
down or up what matters is what happens
over the next 20 years not over the next
three months